good morning believe nation today's
message is achieve professional
excellence over to you tiger woods' TV
there is such a thing as perfection in
because we are human we're all
technically imperfect so how can we ever
achieve perfection but what I can I will
tell you this that I've always been a
big believer of professional excellence
and that's what I trying to achieve I
know I can never get to point where I
hid perfect shots every time and I just
want to become the best I can be and
that to me is professional excellence
it's interesting to me that he talked
about being a perfectionist and trying
to be perfect I find that being a
perfectionist holds a lot of people back
in their business and in their life
because it's impossible to be perfect
it's impossible to be a golfer and get a
hole in one on every hole it's not
possible it's never happened it's not
going to happen and so a lot of people
take that approach in their business
that they don't want to release anything
until it's perfect and I have this
nagging tendency as well it used to be a
lot worse than it is now in my first
business I didn't want to release my
business until I had the perfect
business plan and so I spent an entire
summer just working on my business plan
and I didn't want to release it because
it's not perfect it's not perfect it's
not perfect yet it's got to be exactly
it I'm not gonna release it little did I
know that the perfect business plan does
not exist and that as soon as I launched
out to the market a lot of my
assumptions were wrong and we made a lot
of mistakes and I wish I had gone sooner
and that's the plague that really hurts
perfectionist is that we don't do enough
acting there are some people who just
act too much they're out just trying a
whole bunch of stuff and those people
maybe need to plan a little bit more but
perfectionist they spend too much time
planning I spend too much time in the
past planet maybe even a little bit now
where a lot of people still spend too
much time planning and not enough time
doing and
testing and acting and see if it works
if you are a perfectionist and chances
are that perfections nature can be
really good and make sure your attention
to detail make sure that you don't make
mistakes but the negative side of it is
you playing so much that it holds you
back from actually acting on things that
will help your business grow and changes
are this is something that if a place
you today has plagued you your entire
life and just realizing that and getting
out of the comfort zone a little bit to
act a little bit more instead of
striving for perfection but striving for
professional excellence you have a much
higher chance of achieving success so
the question is that you today is are
you or perfectionist or not and you feel
like it holds you back sometimes leave
it in the comments below I'm going to
join the discussion I also want to give
a quick shout out to Jeromy Oh craft gap
from mentor network dot CA Jeremy thank
you so much for purchasing the copy of
my book really means a lot to me those
are you watching if you want your chains
that I shout it in the future video make
sure to grab a copy of the book and also
email in your receipts that we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one word is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events vessel